Forbes this month is celebrating its
100th birthday happy birthday Forbes BC
Ford's published a first issue of the
magazine
on September 15 1917 since then Forbes
and its iconic rankings like the richest
people in America and the newer 30 under
30 list have guided business investors
and industries the grandson of BC Forbes
Steve Forbes is the editor-in-chief and
chairman of Forbes media he reflected on
Forbes success and his grandfather's
original purpose entrepreneurs around
the world I think feel that we
understand their purpose in life better
than anyone else that we see the real
true mission of what they're trying to
do so they relate to us better than
anyone else and so again we'll point out
when things aren't done right but we
believe in the true purpose of what my
grandfather laid out to create
conditions for the main able people to
have more happiness Forbes is
celebrating with a special centennial
issue featuring essays by the 100
greatest living minds in business for
media CEO and executive chairman Mike
perilous is here good morning good
morning so let's talk about the
qualifications I mean how did you decide
who the 100 are well there's some
subjectivity to it but we look for
people who'd created extreme lasting
impact in the business world and people
who innovated in a way that transcends
others in the in their field and again
leaving a great mark though how does
Warren Buffett fit that mop Warren
Buffett is the poster child for
everything we stand for he is arguably
the world's greatest investor he's
redefining philanthropy and as Steve
said a moment ago he defines the the the
notion that making money shouldn't be
all it's about it should be about being
happy he's a happy man and I say I
looked at this and I said what does this
mean first ever a I cover what does that
mean well Warren worked closely with us
and a company called fluid AI and if you
take you download an app you take a
picture of that cover and a
three-dimensional image holograph of
Warren pops up and he'll answer
questions it's been loaded with AI
he'll answer questions about business
and finance and even his own personal
journey he it's got nuance if you ask
him about politics he'll dodge it you
know what else I thought was so
interesting is that you had them all
write their own essays to us fry
themselves is there an essay that stood
out for you that you said I know they're
all good but one that you said that's
really good well I have one that's
poignant and one that's kind of fun and
interesting the poignant woman was
Jacqueline Novogratz founders the acumen
fund just wonderful and she says
concentrate on character don't worry
about your reputation if your character
is good you don't have to guard your
reputation others will do it for you and
then Richard Branson who I think
channels Malcolm Forbes and represents
his brand in everything that he does
wrote a piece you know he's always doing
something crazy and attention-grabbing
and important and when they launched the
Virgin Atlantic route to Las Vegas he
entered the surprise party via bungee
cord from several stories up in the
building but he missed like Malcolm 4
bungee cord was the wrong length he hit
the side of the building he tore his
clothes his face and legs were bloodied
and that's how he entered the party is
there a common theme from all these
essays is there one thing that sort of
gives them they're really all over the
place but they talk about something
that's meaningful and important to them
in terms of the success they've enjoyed
as businesspeople
that's an often the word one word often
comes back as curiosity yes it did from
Jeff Bezos this weekend yes yeah I think
curiosity Marc Benioff big personality
big brain big guy and you describe him
as a unicorn unicorn will he built a
business venture venture capital with
that exceeded a billion dollars in value
valuation but he talks about your point
about curiosity he talks about keeping a
beginners mentality if you live in the
past you're not going to be an innovator
and those are the kinds of things people
talk about we took photographs using the
same photographer Martin Schuler 18
cities 12 countries so there's a they're
all very different but there's a style
that connects them all
Oprah Winfrey and Diane von Furstenberg
yes totally women later yeah yeah Sheryl
Sandberg Jackson Novogratz wonderful
Mike Pearl is great - thank you here
thank you so much Congrats on 100 years
thank you yeah